Hello and welcome to the second video in the importing asset section.
In this, we will be importing a file from an FBX.
And we will be looking at how you'd go about migrating something from one project to another.
Right, let's look at importing into a project via the file.
For this, we are going to use an FBX.
This is a common format that you would be able to output from something like Maya or Blender.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to start off by opening a new file.
So I'm going to call this Robot.
It's going to be importing a skeletal match for one of our asset packs.
Now, I've got a couple of different options.
But the one I'm going to use here is the import.
If I push import, it's immediately going to jump me into the file explorer,
asking me to find where the files are to be imported.
Now, you're only going to be able to see in this files, which Unreal understands as important.
You can see in this directory, all I have is three PNGs.
If I was to select one of these, it would import it as a texture.
And a SK underscore bot, which is a 3D object and is of type FBX.
FBX is supported by default.
However, there are other versions with plugins you can get the engine to work with.
So I'm now going to select OK.
And it's going to bring me up a huge amount of options.
And now I know that these options work, so I'm not going to mess around with them.
But you can probably find stuff that would work with your pipeline.
So I'm just going to hit import.
And see importing down here.
And then suddenly we've got everything in already.
Now, if I was to drag in our little character here,
and see that it's in the engine, all right, I'm going to push the G button.
I haven't mentioned this yet, but that puts us in game mode.
And that will turn off any of the widgets that we have.
So you can see how something would look when it's in game mode.
And that is working great.
I can even open up the material and see that all of the textures and stuff are connected up.
So it really is quite straightforward, as long as you're using some of the default ones.
It's just a question of finding the file and importing them.
You may find that the preparation for a clean import is a little bit harder,
especially when it comes to materials, because different engines work with materials in different works.
We will touch on that as we go on.
You also find that you can import animations in the same way and apply them to specific skeletal measures.
So that really is the basics of importing from a file.
OK, let's talk about migration.
So that is moving elements from one project to another.
Now, out of the moment, I jumped into another project here,
and I have a mesh from our Quixel collection.
And this is a tree.
And what I want to do is move that into the project that we are working.
So this is how I would go about that.
First thing I would do is I would right-hand click and under asset actions, I would select migrate.
It asked me to save the level.
And what it's going to do then is it's going to go away and find all of the different dependencies,
which would be required in order to get this model to work in the new project.
And it's to be noted, I'm on the same version of the engine, which makes this a lot easier,
makes everything comply.
Now, what I'm going to do is I'm going to go OK.
And then I'm going to the first project and the content directory.
And I'm going to select that.
Now, we're looking to move things into a content directory because otherwise it isn't going to
all of the references route from a content directory.
So in this case, it needs to be in the content.
And select the folder.
Now it's going to go away and migrate all those different assets and validate them.
So here we are back in our original project.
And you can now see that we have this asset directory.
And within the meshes, we have my tree.
I drag this in and take a second for it to be compiled.
Well,
Hey, Presto, the tree is now in the new project,
along with all of its dependencies.
OK, and with that, it brings us to the end of our foundation,
sort of importing assets into Unreal Engine.
Thank you very much.